once again they are free to be the best
see it is howdy there Wayne's the 24
hours
jam-packed with cutting-edge technology
and building out of carbon fiber
this is outies Lamar winning r18 e-tron
restart it's worth millions and millions
and millions of dollars I get to drive
it today count me in way over my head
the key to the r18 success like under
those curved lines a turbo diesel engine
into electric motors working alongside
one another but I'm not allowed to see
it and neither are you
this is top-secret stuff but you're
talking of programs of development which
is a hundred million dollars or more
easily so every car is quite I mean
they're they're quite precious yeah
these cars are very precious and each
one has quite a high value there is no
question on that but this is because
there is technology in that you can't
find anywhere else
this is dr. Wolfgang Ullrich he runs out
a motor sport there is quite some power
and the r18 is his baby I've never even
heard of a civilian like me getting the
chance to drive a race car like this do
people think you're crazy letting
journalists drive this priceless car
today I think we just trusted generally
and pretty much if something happens to
the priceless car they I am responsible
so oh good
but first a training lap in one of
outies slower and slightly less cool
sedans since 9th ranking and sitting
shotgun is Marcel Fassler
one of this year's LeMond people too
early at my farm oh yeah he's showing me
what's what by look ok my eyes are okay
perfect
Lamarr is the toughest most important
endurance race of its kind think of the
Super Bowl and the wolf pup all wrapped
together and win here means bragging
rights for years
Americans may be less familiar but it's
a big deal in Europe it's also a testing
ground for the latest technologies to
put this in perspective this car is
going into an Audi Museum later in the
year I reckon and it's a career pen I
have to learn a track a race car I've
never been in can't even imagine being
and I have the pressure of having the
top tier people watching me do it like
suited up in Harlem
I'm feeling tonight Dean nervous
you forget about driving a car this is
like piloting the space shuttle
there are 40 buns on the steering wheel
the cockpit is as tight as a coffin it's
faster than anything I've ever ever
driven
both model the req can hit 200 miles an
hour
the combustion ended drive the rear
wheel of the electric drive gives the
Sun explosive power out of the curves
Browdy this is the future that is the
singularly most cool thing I've ever
done when the electrical system kicks in
it just it sucks your guts out I've
never felt anything like it I've
actually driven f1 car and it wasn't
even like that the g-forces are pushing
on you like a carnival ride
I'll never probably get to do that again
so try to face today the best day of my
professional life that was cool